hello and welcome to advanced nerd life
study syllabus 3 in today's class we'll
be studying the life cycle of a peculiar
specimen the anime fan alternate names
you may have heard can include otaku
weeaboo and dirty chinese cartoons
loving [ __ ] yes this will be on your
final exam the anime fan originates from
homo sapiens evolved from ancient
primates who stood up on two legs to
become man who then de-evolved back into
primates fleeing [ __ ] at each other for
not liking the same 2d girl they can be
recognized by their unique culture
distinct language and bizarre love for
trash bins many anime fans can look
similar to regular humans though so the
industry-standard litmus test is to
utter the exact phrase smile sweet
sister sadistic surprise service and if
the specimen is an anime fan they will
have to follow up with a word beginning
with s otherwise their heads will
implode all anime fans start their life
often their chrysalis ready to
metamorphosize into they're fully grown
form at this point they may or may not
be aware of what anime is perhaps they
only saw Dragonball Z and Pokemon as a
kid or maybe they've attempted to watch
attack on Titan and have even said that
they like anime but at this point they
still lump shows like avatar and Ruby
into the same category without batting
an eye signifying the lesser developed
brain of this early phase the scientific
name for this stage is referred to as
troops for Twitter a Latin phrase which
in modern English translates
approximately to filthy casual they will
remain in this form until they stumble
upon one show that lights their desire
to actively seek out more anime this
will mark the awakening this lesser
developed mind of an infant anime fan
causes a period of blissful ignorance in
which every anime they watch is
immediately a ten out of ten as they
have not seen anything everything is
good and this triggers a desire to
consume as much anime as they can
awakening the temporary power of time
dilation where they can seemingly
consume 150 episodes of anime a day with
ease even though it literally shouldn't
be physically possible once an
individual grows out of this phase they
will lose this power indefinitely and
consuming anime will never be as easy it
is at this point they will feel the
phenomenon that will truly cement their
transformation the void after watching
an exceptional anime a fan will
experience a sensation of emptiness that
cannot be filled with the only known
remedy being to keep watching anime
I'm not exactly a pleasant feeling it's
a signify that the anime just watch
connected deeply in some way the bigger
the void the bigger the effect the anime
had on the individual though it is a
pretty common feeling to feel the void
during the early stages of an anime fans
life as they age it gets increasingly
harder to find a series that evokes that
same feeling and fans may spend the
whole life chasing that same first void
it is for this reason that in 1995 the
World Health Organization officially
classified anime as a class a drug
joining the likes of cocaine heroin and
that little piece of meat that gets
pinched in at the top of a girl's thigh
highs at some point during or just after
their awakening they may reach a stage
called hentai puberty at this stage
there is a small realization that they
can find anime characters attractive
settle down settle down all those scenes
of sexualized anime girls they used to
find kind of weird slowly start becoming
acceptable then commonplace then
celebrated then the next thing they know
they're claiming that keola kill was
truly revolutionary as a self-aware
statement of this genre for using
half-naked girls battling in kinky
attire even though all it did was give
them an excuse to watch half-naked girls
battling in kinky attire did I mention
that anime fans like watching half-naked
girls battling in kinky attire specimens
of the female gender may go through an
extra stage here known as yaoi
menstruation a sudden awakening of a
sixth sense cause going to gravitate
towards any and all sources of male
homosexuality once finished with
adolescence subjects will start
developing this thing called taste this
will signify a maturity in the life
cycle allowing for interactions within
their kind as the comparable level of
one's taste excrements is the main form
of communication within the species this
is when they start understanding what
appeals to them and started lining
themselves with certain factions if they
find that they're like a lot of shows in
the shown in John referral they are
known as shown and tarts Gundam fans are
known as Gundam Todd's Maui fans are
known as MOA tars and Idol fans are
known as cancer they may even find that
a show causes them to have such a
deep-rooted appreciation that they want
to show their appreciation in another
way than simply just watching it which
unavoidably leads to merchandise well
the idea of spending money on anime
trinkets may have seemed alien before
once their merchandise virginity is
taken there is no looking
back whilst ours has a small purchase of
a cool poster gradually leads to bigger
and bigger purchases before eventually
they are selling their left kidney to
the black market to pre-order that
limited-edition Giovanni you make a
figure that goes on sale next year if
they ever reach the stage it is highly
advised that they stay away from anime
conventions as this rare event allows
the user to temporarily break their
limiters to become an unstoppable
spending machine bypassing any form of
logic and reason coming out the steep
drawback of not having any money to
cover the cost of existing for a while
at some point the individual may find
that a character makes them feel
something special something that's not
sexual mostly not entirely
okay so there's another emotion aside
from popping a bone this is the first
love the species themselves refer to
this special character as a waifu or
husband oh there is not any concrete
pattern in what constitutes an anime
fans have a high affinity towards a
certain character but in-depth research
suggests that more often than not it was
a blush or smile they would literally
sell their left testicle to protect as
with love within the human species the
first love for an anime fan will rarely
be their last some may find one they
stick with forever and some will just
jump ship every season depending on
which girl is most mo a like the
unfaithful gets that they are but they
will for the most part stick to one
waifu or husband o at the same time as
anyone who doesn't is publicly ousted
tortured then sentenced to death by
stoning which is totally reasonable
eventually the anime fan may feel the
urge to discuss anime with others but
finds that people only want to discuss
shows that have aired recently this is
the time where they can find themselves
entering the seasonal anime arms race
here they enter a perpetual cycle of
consumption where the main objective is
to spend every waking hour farming as
much anime is humanly possible for that
current season under the pretense that
they just need to keep up to date with
the current overall conversation
surrounding anime at this stage they are
truly tested on their mental fortitude
memory of anime watch is restricted to
the past three months they become a
devout follower of the religion known as
the three Episode rule and any title
older than two years get transported to
a separate realm unreachable by a
current knowledge of physics also known
as the plan to watch lists unfortunately
as they have lost the power of time
dilation they had during their awakening
keeping up with that much anime is
infinitely harder and
when they inevitably fall off their
schedule by milliseconds this starts a
domino effect which they can never
recover from and transforms into a
permanent state of always being behind
this comes with a high risk of burnout
the unfortunate number one cause of
death within the species this leap can
only be broken once the subject comes to
realize that they are essentially
grinding for XP to reach an indistinct
uncapped level of anomie consumption
where the only rewards are their own
self-loathing once enough anime has been
watched many can begin to feel
knowledgeable enough to start
understanding anime on a deeper level
which is when they enter what they
perceive to be the highest state of
being when referring to shows they start
using words like pacing and narrative
and if they're feeling really spicy
discourse even if no one in the world
really knows how to use those words
correctly their archenemy becomes their
former selves the tasteless casual and
things start surprising them less and
less eventually they don't even know if
they enjoy anime anymore but what they
do know is everyone else is enjoying it
wrong some spiral downwards on a journey
to refine their taste in anime are
fruitless journey as not many know the
sacrifices that have to be made to
achieve the perfect taste in anime for
once one achieves the perfect taste in
anime anime becomes [ __ ] only once they
have cycled through all these stages
where they reach their final stage true
acceptance had this most mature points
in their lifecycle an anime fan will
come to accept who they really are and
enter a rebirth having achieved oneness
with their self-identity
sure they could watch every show in the
season sure they could break down why
the works of me sucking us are
revolutionary to the medium sure they've
seen the obscure shows that go under
appreciated by everyone but sometimes
you just got to watch some stupid harem
fanservice crash with a cinder a love
interest that you grew up loving and
enjoy the hell out of it cuz you know
what that's completely okay while we
refer to this final stage as true
acceptance anime fans may know it as a
better term no longer giving a [ __ ] this
is when they finally realize they have
ended up exactly on the path they began
back at their awakening with the same
shitty taste as the final revolution is
to regress back to their infancy though
they have learned one important thing
that separates them from the same
bright-eyed kid that first
but anime before one can have a [ __ ]
taste one must first have no taste and
thus the cycle of the enemy fan is
complete hey guys hope you enjoyed the
video thank you very much this month to
Lee Watts
tun grin Robert Hahn Borg K must live
and everyone else on patreon for helping
to support me for this month and making
this video possible well it is December
now so you know that means it's time for
me to lock myself up my room and work on
the year on end review I'm taking bets
now will not be on splice both paths
before the end of the year or will it
come out in March knowing you guys I'm
sure you're still probably gonna say oh
uploading in March anyway that's it from
me no further updates to date I've been
gig ugh and I will see you all next time